queridos amigos amigas Cuba Lleva más de
60 años bajo el yugo de la dictadura
castrista un periodo de tiempo durante
el cual esta Isla se ha convertido en
uno de los países más pobres de todo
América una situación que ha provocado
según los cálculos disponibles que a
pesar de tener poco más de 11 millones
de habitantes tan solo Durante los
últimos 25 años más de un millón de
personas hayan tenido que abandonar La
Isla hablamos de un enorme Éxodo que
lejos de frenarse está cobrando cada vez
más y más velocidad para que os hagáis
una idea tan solo Durante los nueve
primeros meses del 2022 se calcula que
cerca de 200.000 cubanos escaparon de La
Isla rumbo a los Estados Unidos un
máximo histórico que supera a cualquier
época anterior así que ya os podéis
hacer una idea de lo mal que están las
cosas en Cuba pronto os hablaremos de
ello la rutendido por supuesto aquí en
visualpolitik
El caso es que a pesar de esta
complicada situación Por lo general La
dictadura castrista no ha tenido nunca
mala prensa Sí a ver Prácticamente todo
el mundo acepta que cubase una dictadura
pero una dictadura con apellido siempre
siempre han existido mitos que han
contribuido a blanquear la imagen del
castrismo y de hecho Aunque parezca
increíble Fidel Castro fue uno de los
políticos más populares de toda
latinoamérica durante el siglo XX Y sí
lo sabemos Fidel Tuvo muchos detractores
pero amigos amigas también muchos
partidarios y muchos incondicionales y
precisamente una de las estrategias de
comunicación más efectivas del régimen
cubano ha sido enviar regularmente a
cientos y cientos miles de médicos a
países con problemas sí sin duda los
médicos cubanos se han hecho muy famosos
desde Italia hasta Jamaica o Venezuela
pasando por todo tipo de crisis y
desastres a lo largo y ancho del mundo
sin embargo hubo un momento porque
sabías que estas misiones médicas le
generan ingresos millonarios al régimen
pues queridos amigos amigas En este
vídeo os contaremos Cómo surge uno de
los mejores negocios generados por la
Habana en los últimos 50 años atentos
[Aplausos]
pero antes os hago una pregunta hablando
de autocracias el 20 congreso del
partido comuni no ha reelegido sin pin
para un tercer mandato sin embargo pese
a yo el líder chino no puede estar
tranquilo el país está experimentando
una fuerte desaceleración económica y el
pinchazo de una brutal burbuja
inmobiliaria que ahora amenaza con
arrastrar a todo el sector financiero y
la pregunta es realmente china hasta las
puertas de sufrir una enorme crisis
financiera cómo piensa el gobierno dar
la vuelta a esta situación Pues no te
pierdas el vídeo que si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera demostrativos con el que
participamos le ha dedicado a esta
cuestión os dejo el enlace en la
descripción y en los comentarios pero
dicho esto sumerjámonos ya en lo más
profundo de la estrategia política más
efectiva del castrismo atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con el paso de los años la medicina
cubana se ha convertido en uno de los
grandes mitos del régimen castrista
seguro que casi todos habéis escuchado
esta historia la de un pueblo castigado
por el diabólico bloqueo norteamericano
que sin embargo pesa todo y contra
viento y marea supera todas las
adversidades y logra construir un
sistema de salud de vanguardia mundial
Lástima que la historia real sea
bastante diferente especialmente si eres
un ciudadano de a pie Sí es verdad que
Cuba destina gran parte de sus recursos
al sistema médico de hecho se estima que
esta apuesta es de aproximadamente un
11% del pib y supuestamente eso le ha
permitido estadísticas relativamente
buenas en materias como la esperanza
media de vida o la mortalidad infantil
sin embargo hay un pequeño problema este
estudio de Oxford que veis en pantalla
Aventura que estas estadísticas están
manipuladas Y que además se ven sesgadas
por su propia situación económica por
ejemplo en la isla no hay prácticamente
coches y sin coches no hay accidentes
fatales en la carretera además en Cuba
no existe un único sistema de salud sino
que cohabitan al menos dos sistemas
diferentes
por un la respuesta del sistema
sanitario tanto para extranjeros como
para la élite cubana un sistema que
tiene la misión de conseguir Divisas
extranjeras con el turismo médico y por
supuesto como os podéis imaginar Este es
el sistema de vanguardia de la isla y
está vetado a los cubanos corrientes
estos tienen acceso a un sistema
sanitario totalmente diferente un
sistema donde la infraestructura se
desmorona y donde faltan todo tipo de
suministros para que os hagáis una idea
Cuando un paciente tiene que acudir a
uno de estos hospitales populares tiene
que llevar consigo sus propias sábanas
sus propias toallas la comida o el jabón
las imágenes amigos amigas hablan por sí
mismas la historia es totalmente
diferente a la que tantas veces
escuchamos 14 de mayo de 2022 Cuba
reconoce una fuerte escasez de
medicamentos para todo tipo de
enfermedades en cualquier caso lo que
resulta innegable es que Cuba se ha
elaborado una reputación tan buena que
los amigos del régimen pues no dudan en
trasladarse a la isla para tratarse de
cualquier problema médico como podéis
ver la crema de la crema marzo de 2017
Evo Morales anticipa su viaje a Cuba
para someterse a una operación noviembre
de 2012 Chávez vieja Cuba a someterse a
un tratamiento especial el parlamento
venezolano autoriza el presidente
ausentarse por tiempo indefinido marzo
de 2020 no sé cómo decirle gracias a
este país dijo Florencia kirchner en su
despedida de Cuba la hija de la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández y del
fallecido es mandatario Néstor kirchner
describió brevemente en su cuenta de
Instagram su Estancia y tratamiento en
el país caribeño antes de regresar a la
Argentina
abril de 2020 donde está Daniel Ortega
la larga ausencia del presidente
nicaragüense en medio de la pandemia del
coronavirus estimula rumores sobre su
salud dura manatellez Quien fuera
miembro del gabinete de Ortega en los
años 80 considera muy posible que esté
en Cuba de una forma u otra la sanidad
cubana se ha convertido en uno de los
grandes instrumentos de poder blando de
la isla un enorme altavoz para la
revolución Seguro seguro que todos
recordáis noticias como estas
[Música]
22 de marzo de 2020 Cuba envía Italia y
América Latina brigadas médicas para
enfrentar el coronavirus 29 de marzo de
2020 médicos cubanos van andorra su
segundo destino europeo contra la Kobe
19 15 de junio de 2020 médicos cubanos
se quedarían en México más de lo
previstos y casos de Kobe 19 aumentan
Incluso en septiembre del año 2005 Fidel
Castro ordenó la creación de un
contingente internacional de médicos
destinados a ayudar a Estados Unidos
tras el paso del huracán Katrina por
Nueva Orleans dicho grupo recibió el
nombre de brigada médica internacional
Henry y más adelante esta brigada ha
sido trabajando llegando incluso a ser
galardonada por la Organización Mundial
de la Salud por su participación en
África en cuanto a la contención del
brote del ébola y claro con todo esto La
pregunta es qué se esconde realmente
detrás de todas estas misiones es todo
tan limpio como parece Pues bien en este
vídeo vamos a descubrir que hay detrás
de todas estas operaciones esta queridos
amigos amigas es la otra cara de la
mejor herramienta diplomática de Cuba
atentos
salud diplomacia y solidaridad
revolucionaria
en 1963 tuvo lugar la guerra de las
Arenas un conflicto bélico entre Argelia
y Marruecos donde Cuba intervino en un
contexto geopolítico donde la isla solía
tomar parte en distintas guerras a favor
de los bardos aliados con la unión
soviética Claro que en esta ocasión
ocurrió algo muy particular la falta de
médicos en la zona hizo que hace del
Castro se le ocurriera la estrategia de
enviar brigadas de profesionales de la
salud para cubrir esa carencia y asistir
así a los soldados y a las víctimas del
conflicto fue el primer ensayo de una
política que sería cada vez más masiva
más común y más sistemática Aunque aquí
tenemos que hacer un pequeño inciso
puede que te sorprenda Pero entre 1960 y
1990 las fuerzas armadas cubanas
protagonizaron al menos ocho
intervenciones militares en el mundo
cinco de ellas fueron en África Argelia
Siria Congo Angola y Etiopía y el resto
en Centroamérica y el Caribe digamos que
Durante los tiempos de la unión
soviética el ejército Cubano se
convirtió en toda una tropa
expedicionaria al servicio de la
Revolución comunista sin embargo el
creciente fracaso de todas estas
expediciones comenzó a empujar a Castro
a concebir otra forma distinta de
influir en terceros países una forma
quizás un poco más amistosa y es así
como tras la experiencia evangelia se
fue cocinando A fuego lento la curiosa
estrategia de las brigadas médicas
desde aquí el primer ensayo de 1963 y
según las cifras promovidas por el
propio régimen alrededor de 600.000
trabajadores cubanos de la salud han
prestado servicios médicos en más de 160
países y ojo porque actualmente son unos
30.000 los médicos cubanos que parecen
estar activos y desplegados en 67 países
de todo el mundo hablamos de un sistema
de poder blando bien engrasado tanto a
nivel logístico como económico sobre
todo cuando tenemos en cuenta que Cuba
ha hecho de esta actividad un enorme
business Sí sí me has escuchado bien un
enorme lucrativo negocio atentos
[Música]
un negocio muy rentable para el régimen
a ver Cuba es un país tradicionalmente
hermético en todo aquello que involucra
al gobierno es lo que tiene la
dictaduras que no son precisamente los
lugares más transparentes sin embargo
pese a yo a partir del año 2000
comenzaron a conocerse algunos métodos y
algunas normas respecto al reclutamiento
y la financiación de los programas de
médicos por el mundo unos
descubrimientos que la verdad no casaban
nada bien con los derechos más
elementales de cualquier trabajador y
algo más tarde en marzo del año 2010 el
gobierno cubano adicto a la resolución
número 168 la cual establece el
reglamento disciplinario para los
trabajadores civiles cubanos que prestan
servicios en el exterior fijaos
[Música]
este documento ha sido muy controvertido
desde que se dio a conocer entre otras
cosas por las infracciones que establece
en torno a la disciplina relacionada con
el prestigio y la conducta social de los
colaboradores por ejemplo este
reglamento sanciona comportamientos como
estos que veis en pantalla artículo 8.g
sostener relaciones con nacionales o
extranjeros cuya conducta no este acorde
Con los principios y valores de la
sociedad artículo 8.j sostener
relaciones de amistad de otro tipo con
ciudadanos cubanos residentes o no en el
país donde se presta la colaboración y
que se constituyan en promotores de un
modo de vida contrario a los principios
que deben caracterizar a un colaborador
cubano en el exterior y artículo 8.p no
informar a Los Superiores de los
obsequios que reciba de parte de los
nacionales o extranjeros es decir nada
de confraternizar con personas no
revolucionarias sino comunistas Y por
supuesto nada de mantener relaciones
incluso de amistad que no se han
notificadas y aprobadas por Los
Superiores
[Música]
y Estos son tan solo tres ejemplos de un
largo larguísimo reglamento
disciplinario que regula cada punto de
la vida de los trabajadores médicos en
el exterior y por supuesto todos los
médicos cubanos quedan sometidos al
código penal en caso de que se deje
tentar por las comodidades capitalistas
que se puedan encontrar en aquellos
países donde prestan servicios el
funcionario o empleado público encargado
de cumplir alguna misión en otro país
que la abandone o cumplido esta o
requerido en cualquier momento para que
regrese se niega expresado tácitamente a
hacerlo incurre en sanción de privación
de libertad de 3 a 8 años
artículo 176.1 del Código Penal de Cuba
visto lo visto no sé no parece que un
código tan estricto y con un control tan
amplio de la vida de los trabajadores
pues encaje bien con la imagen de
médicos voluntarios acudiendo a prestar
ayuda desinteresada y la pregunta es
habrá truco
pues lo cierto Es que en 2019 la
relatorías especiales de las Naciones
Unidas sobre la trata de personas y las
formas contemporáneas de esclavitud
dedicaron parte de su trabajo a Cuba y
el circuito económico diseñado para
recaudar millones de dólares a partir de
estas misiones ya no tan humanitarias
entre otras cosas está relatoras le
pidieron al gobierno cubano que
explicará estas informaciones y tomar
medidas al respecto fijaos el gobierno
de Cuba recibiría una suma de dinero de
los gobiernos anfitriones y pagaré a los
trabajadores una parte de dichos fondos
en los países donde el gobierno
anfitrión paga directamente al
trabajador cubano este debe devolver al
gobierno de Cuba un porcentaje de su
salario que aumentaría el 75% o hasta el
90% de su salario mensual relativa
especial de la ONU sobre las formas
contemporáneas de la esclavitud 2019 es
decir No solo no pueden tener relaciones
no aprobadas negarse a trabajar o Buscar
establecerse en otros países sino que
los sanitarios cubanos tampoco reciben
un pago coherente con su labor
[Música]
según un informe de prisión es defenders
de los 10.700 dólares por tres meses
aproximadamente
3.560 dólares al mes Que pagó el
gobierno mexicano por cada uno de los
585 médicos y enfermeros cubanos que
prestan servicio en la capital del país
la Habana solo les dio 600 dólares para
tres meses como cobro fijo en el país
unos 200 dólares por mes es decir el
gobierno de Cuba se quedó en primera
instancia con el 94,4% del montante que
cobro por sus médicos y les dio a estos
una miseria con la que no es posible ni
la digna subsistencia en México
pero eso no es todo la responsable de
Naciones Unidas también pidieron
aclaraciones sobre las jornadas y los
horarios de trabajo que obligan a
desempeñar a los sanitarios los médicos
trabajarían 48 horas por semana más 16
adicionales de guardia lo cual aumenta
un total de 64 horas semanales muchas
veces incluyendo sábados y domingos el
exceso de las trabajadas ilustra la
explotación laboral a la cual estarían
sometidos los médicos cubanos en el
exterior relator especial de la ONU
sobre las formas de la esclavitud 2019
ya lo veis todo al servicio de la
Revolución o mejor dicho de los
mandamases de la revolución
y estas condiciones fueron precisamente
las que hicieron que en junio del año
2021 el propio parlamento europeo
condenará el sistema de emisiones
médicas cubanas por primera vez una gran
institución política señaló claramente
la naturaleza real de las misiones
cubanas fijaos si el parlamento europeo
condena las violaciones sistemáticas de
los derechos humanos y laborales
cometidas por el estado cubano contra su
personal sanitario enviado a prestar
servicios en el extranjero emisiones
médicas resolución del parlamento
europeo de 10 de junio de 2021 sobre los
derechos humanos y la situación política
en Cuba pero un momento porque Más allá
de la explotación laboral y la
influencia diplomática y el poder blando
las misiones sanitarias de Cuba pueden
llegar a tener otro objetivo mucho más
pelea agudo Ni más ni menos que exportar
directamente la revolución atentos
Más allá de las apariencias
nadie lo duda Venezuela ha sido el país
donde probablemente más han intervenido
las misiones de médicos cubanos de hecho
el propio Hugo Chávez hizo del tema uno
de sus ejes de campaña y los comicios
presidenciales del año 2012 se dan
cuenta todo eso lo cerraría el majunche
todo eso se acabaría porque lo primero
que ellos harían sería
expulsar a esos hermanos y hermanas
nuestras que han venido aquí a servirle
al pueblo venezolano pero que la
burguesía venezolana odia los hijos y
las hijas de Fidel Castro El padre de
todos los revolucionarios de este
continente Usted sabe que el régimen
venezolano mantenía bueno y mantiene una
estrecha colaboración con la Habana y
que también a cambio de los médicos
cubanos Venezuela le entregaba petróleo
al régimen castrista pero la cuestión es
que eso no es todo se sospecha y hay
indicios bastante claros de que estas
brigadas en muchos casos actuaron
también como una especie de Caballo de
Troya gracias a ella y como parte de los
equipos médicos muchos miembros de la
inteligencia cubana se desplegaron en
Venezuela para infiltrar todos los
resortes de la sociedad y apoyar al
régimen de Chávez
por eso cuando recientemente el gobierno
mexicano de Andrés Manuel López Obrador
anunció un programa similar Aunque mucho
más pequeño de médicos cubanos saltaron
las alarmas sobre las consecuencias que
esto Podría tener sobre el riesgo de que
la inteligencia cubana intenta
aprovechar estas misiones para hacer lo
mismo que ya hizo en Venezuela intentar
controlar el país y sembrar la llama de
la Revolución O al menos que utilice
esta red para desarrollar y explotar
negocios ilegales con los que conseguir
influencia y Divisas extranjeras que
también es muy importante en Cuba dado
que en este caso despliegues muy pequeño
el riesgo real parece muy limitado Pero
qué queréis que os diga tener a los
servicios de inteligencia cubanos
operando abiertamente en un país No
parece la mejor noticia del mundo Pues
bien esta es la otra cara de las
misiones médicas cubanas unas misiones
con las que no solo se explota miles
sanitarios como si fueran mano de obras
clave sino que el régimen las utiliza
como instrumento de poder blando e
incluso en algunos casos como un
mecanismo para infiltrarse en otros
países así que ya sabéis la próxima vez
que veis alguna noticia sobre estos
acuerdos mucho ojo porque esta es una de
las estrategias de influencia y
generación de Divisas más importantes
para una de las dictaduras más
influyentes de las últimas décadas
porque ya lo sabéis en política
internacional aparecen esto puede llegar
a esconder una realidad terrible pero
dicho esto turno para ti conocías estas
operaciones de Cuba en todo el mundo Qué
te parece en este tipo de estrategias
déjanos tus impresiones por aquí abajo
en los comentarios y ahora hablamos
debate y ahora si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros que aún no lo
habéis hecho una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]